hey what's going on folks I've got
another spoiler video for you guys today
but I just want to ask you guys one
question real quick are you ready to go
capture some whites because that is
exactly what Jon Snow is gonna be doing
next season well at least that's what
he's gonna be trying to do Game of
Thrones is preparing to film some new
scenes and they are in a new location
that will be used for scenes that are
north of the wall
HBO's production team has arrived in
Iceland which is a place they have
filmed than before every time they have
filmed in Iceland they use these icy
landscapes for scenes north of the wall
and this time is gonna be no different
and most of you already know what's up
Jon Snow Jorah Mormont
tormund in the Hound we'll be travelling
north of the wall so they can capture a
white Jon wants to take a white south so
he can prove to all the Lords that there
is a threat and that the threat is real
and during this scene Jon and company
will get attacked by the night's king
and hundreds or even thousands of whites
and that's when Danny shows up with her
dragons and flies everyone to safety but
Jon and Jon is nearly killed but that's
when his uncle Benjen shows up and
sacrifices himself to save Jon and he I
guess he's supposed to put Jon on his
horse and send him off to safety
and that's when benjin gets swarmed by
all the whites and pretty much killed in
this scene is gonna be filmed on a
frozen lake that Jon gets surrounded on
which they have already set up and had
been filming on Jon has already been
seen filming on this set in the men that
Jon will have with him on this mission
which are tormund Ora the Hound and
benjin have already been in Ireland with
Jon filming this action-packed sequence
some other characters were reported to
go with them but they have yet to be
seen so they may have changed the script
a little bit after the big leak came out
I'm not really sure or the characters
might have just been able to lay low why
they've been filming you just haven't
been seen yet but if you guys didn't see
my last spoiler video which I released a
few days ago I said the only person
missing from this was Daenerys but she
has arrived in Ireland and has begun
filming in the studios there and I
guarantee you guys
is filming the dragon scenes where she
is torching some whites I think while
John and his team are in Iceland today
that's exactly what she's going to be
doing John has arrived in Iceland
already and according to another fan
they said they also spotted jorah
mormont up there as well so this is
absolutely going down John and his team
will be filming in Iceland for possibly
a few weeks and these scenes will more
than likely be them traveling through
the north in search of this white they
want to capture and I think this is
where tormund is actually going to come
into great use he knows the land north
of the wall better than any of them so
he's going to help them stay relatively
undetected while they you know travel
through the north trying to find this
white until they come face-to-face with
the night's king who probably already
knows they are coming and he's probably
gonna set a trap for John at least
that's how I feel I feel like the
night's Kings gonna bait John in that
way he can surround all them on this
lake but I'm getting very excited for
this now that everybody's arriving in
Iceland we are gonna be getting a lot
more reports and photos very soon which
I will report on as soon as possible
I usually try to have a video up within
a few hours of each new report that
comes out that way you guys can see them
first right here so hopefully you guys
enjoy these updates so far this is all
we have since the holidays but stay
tuned my friends because much more is
gonna be coming out and days to come and
I also just want to say real quick I
cannot wait to have another scene to
where John and the night's king lock
eyes again that's gonna be so intense
this time and if John actually is able
to one-up the night's king and get south
of one of the whites the night's king is
gonna be so pissed off I can't wait to
see how this goes down
he's definitely gonna want to huff and
puff and blow down that damn wall if
John gets away with one of his men so
can't wait for that guys stay tuned as
soon as I get some more news I will be
releasing them as soon as possible and
as always thanks for listening guys and
have a great day bye